Sáng 18, tài hành quý hợp với eBay Group Việt Nam, tổ chất bối gặp gỡ chuyển thông cuộc bộ đối
vình thoại SIPC, Nga. Nga. Sau khi họ đáp chuyển bay dài từ Oslo, Nga. Hành sĩ tria sẽ
sự hảo hốc trước đêm dễn đặc biệt, SIPC, Nga. Lại SIPC, Nga.
Tối mùa tâm tham mởi, tại Trung tâm hộ nghị quốc xà Mỹ định. Đây là con sớt thứ ba,
trong chuyển sự an ấm nhà quốc tế vì cộng đồng, Cút Monning Việt Nam, sau thành công của Kén Nhi G và Bòn,
với tàn bộ xanh thu được dành trong một lịch thiệt nguyện. Lần đầu tiên biểu diễn tại Việt Nam,
SIPC, Nga. Tình trọng hà nội làm việc mở đầu cho tôi liệu diễn tàn cầu kiến nghiệp bà miếng năm xử dập.
Trình chính sẽ giới thiệu những tác phẩm nổi tiếng nhất của nhóm được chia thành ba chủ đề về
thiên diên con người và phán thoá, mặc đậm sức mở bắc ổ. SIPC, Nga. Gông hai thành viên,
Rô Vlov Lan và Fiu Nui La Sherry là nhóm nhạc nổi tiếng thế giới với bản U-Race Mi-A,
cùng hơn một miên phyên bản caver. Hàng xị bài tạo sức xúc động trước tình cảm của Khánh Giá Viet và mong muốn mạng đến một điểm Nhạc Sô Sa,
Đảng Cấp, Nhân Gân Gũi, Nhân Monc Quả Chí Anh Gười đến người yêu nhạc Việt Nam.